six rip
i take that back six to three lenovo
breaks the seal good help right there
good recognition by mason
deflected pass loose
picked up by bridges
[Applause]
lamello
[Applause]
look them all
with a dribble in the eyes pull them up
three just set him up so nicely
to get a good look
third
second quarter triple for lavello
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
he meant to do that
excellent play
uber could have forced a shot right
there he said no we got good momentum
where's my point guard halfway through
our third quarter
[Applause]
this guy
loves to play the game
let's play under the screen holiday
that's a mistake easy
knock that one in and hold the follow
through
[Applause]
[Music]
just in case you forgot
number two was in the game oh let it be
known
701 for cleveland
long three lamelo
lamello bald hit seven out of nine
ball
seven of
nine the other night knocks down a deep
one there he's got a good one here patty
mills
on the triple drive set brown up for
that one lavello
got it
three ball for number two
middle's just standing there with his
hands down lamelo says okay
i think patty mills is just going to
stand right there
but
it doesn't bother the reigning
it's interesting marcus smart i've been
picking
[Music]
been down double figures in every game
they played this year and come back to
win
lamella
that's his second three of the
wonderful chemistry with these two
they were born to play with each other
lamelo
[Applause]
slumly working the passing lane knocks
it away
hornets the lead in the ball up by three
lamelo
[Applause]
oh what a wonderful second quarter for
the locals
[Applause]
[Music]
don't do it like that young fella
his fifth three-pointer he's five for
seven from out there it was not fair
[Applause]
he's a game shooter dell i watch you
warm up every game
you like that warm up look at
that touchdown
look at this ball handling right here
behind the back step back hold your
follow through on a one leg jumper
that's all good young felt
swagger look at this i mean they
switched smart one of the best defenders
on the celtics nothing they could do
there
[Applause]
look at this
switch right there
not aggressive poor communication a
point away from the century mark
lamello
only the big ones
he only wants the big shots a triple for
the reigning rookie of the year
that hit a three really had come close
all gate anthony goes under
bad decision at the wrong time word
wants it on the block
hornets instead give it to lamella who
swoops it over to rozier
[Music]
really spreads the floor now he's got
four shooters on the floor along with
nurkic just gonna get lillard
good easy drive straight line drive the
bucket past miles
he's better than that draw iron
[Music]
hornets down by seven
hornets down by
dj washington into the game along with
cody martin
only two starters for the hornets rozier
and ball
[Applause]
first
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bridges
he's got allen on him
shot clocks down to four
huge shot
rain maker chicken salad
that is
with half a grenade he's this i just got
to find some kind of space to get it up
terry
[Music]
probably keeps it for the hornets
lamelo
he's doing a lot of dirty work
throws it right out to lamello's all
alone one two three
hornets on a run
[Applause]
big one
this kid's incredible
[Applause]
look at this shot right here
alan
doesn't match up cody martin over to the
mellow ball
extra pass into the corner lamella wide
open
and the offensive rebound keeps with the
hornets two for a quarter yeah there you
go all right
barnes
blocked from behind by martin and cody
gets it back after the save by hayward
all right things starting to go the way
of the hornets luke walton knows it he
has to call timeout
plumley back out to lavello
double clutched and still hit it yeah
that little clutch froze fox
calmly finds him
and plumley with the rip away
here we go back to back three's
limitless ball
a second year with the clippers he likes
the la air out here
lavello
again
welcome home my friend
cody martin just hit that three he is
nine for 18 from behind the arc this
year phil golly how do you do lavello
ball martin knocks it down and i love
this matchup right here oil says okay
i know you're a good defender but you're
going to give me space here out of the
pack pushing it probably running the
floor
can't get the layup to go dave is
contested now a three point is on its
way and ball knocks it down and a
timeout frank vogel that can linger all
season if you're not careful so
the lakers are being smart but i agree
as lamelo ball
knocks down a three as a shot clock
winding down and then a re-acclimation
period
when the lakers get some of their pieces
back including lebron
ball will fire a three and he's got it
lamelo ball knocks down the triple
goalie ball miles took it right to
jackson just didn't fall
[Applause]
here's lavello's first shot oh that's
true it's a three-ball
[Music]
deep one
got it
had his legs taken up by dillon brooks
too talking about lomelo look at the
ball movement right there a couple of
guys could have shot the ball inside
lamella wants to foul brooks caruso back
ball he's got space
[Applause]
here's caruso the ball loves the corner
three and six in it
to put the bulls back on top another one
from lonzo he's gonna come back in the
world small misses that one baby ryan
right there get it there's johnson back
out ball tries again for three
two four dollars bang bang bang
he watches he's in there working against
two pelicans goes in says man this is a
big boy basketball
i guess that rebound gives the bulls a
second opportunity
and that 10 from green four for caruso
three points and six rebounds for alexei
johnson that's a three from one
[Applause]
and this one was one of the deepest of
the night from alonso
[Applause]
sriracha
good pass out of the post the extra pass
for lonzo ball
bulls running derozan no
scrapping for the loose ball
lonzo left to low
give me the hot sauce
[Music]
jumper for paul and the three is good
well he's not into me because he's only
five one he was a horse shotgun
he's sitting there you know he wrote
it he wrote
he can shoot the basketball levine to
johnson to brown to ball that's a three
oh
big baller
five scored by toronto after the bulls
took a nine point lead levine still
doesn't have a field goal derozan
beautiful extra pass on open ball
give me the hot sauce four three
pointers for lonzo ball in the first
half
there's williams
working on barnes the kick to ball
looking for his fifth three of the night
big baller
he's involved with
nba africa his own foundation
numerous other charities here in chicago
both of his buckets have come on
offensive rebounds early ball will fire
a three and second
and lonzo is gonna have to pick up his
scoring too one two titles with joe keem
noah at florida and he is back in a
celtics jersey there's no need for him
to get open like that with devonta bang
bang bang it's on ball this time oh my
goodness
rebound derozan here comes the push
this is where the bulls have an
advantage
ball sets and fires and bro
give me the hot sauce four threes in the
first three minutes of the game
[Applause]
green sets the screen oh big baller he's
done it three times in the early going
to eight stretch for boston
knocked away by brown into the hands of
levine out to ball for a much needed
three oh needed that one his fourth of
the first half
and they're trying to take away that
mid-range game
caruso to ball quarter three
oh big ball
good find by caruso
you gotta stay in front of him and make
him a shooter
oh mountain house
derozan cross court for a ball triple
that's good bang bang bang good sequence
for lonzo ball the last two trips
[Music]
levine for vujovich ball's open big shot
bang bang
third three of the night for lonzo ball
and the bulls are within four with a
minute to play
what struck me just from the outside
first couple weeks is this team looks
like it's having fun offensively
[Applause]
then the other night only two turnovers
nice bounce back for harden the other
night against toronto
oh that's a great
big baller
the bulls can put together a strong
offensive possession here
derozan cutting buchovich passing extra
pass to green ball for three oh bang
bang bang
ball quick trigger
[Applause]
porzingis who is back for a third
straight game after he had missed five
with a lower back issue it's all about
staying healthy for him runs over
gives
[Applause]
a couple of triples
two passes
reset the ball three to shoot oh that's
a deep one from lonzo
oh that was all the way from kankakee
give me the hot sauce third three for
lonzo ball to tie the game mavericks had
scored 33 points in the last eight
minutes
yeah
there's ball catching shoot that's his
fourth grade
nifty pass
[Applause]
give me the hot sauce
play's actually bigger than he actually
watch it he comes up and goes right
between give me that
that is a big time rebound and then
there's ball right there bang bang bang
all set up with the effort from javonte
green who gives you
and hardaway can jump harder we can jump
oh yeah
that's that's a credit to jamante green
that's
on this side of the floor together
[Applause]
oh
wow i'm doing it with a bunch of guys
[Music]
and the bulls are back up by eight